hails of guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to the setup video of the Sparky
game engine series so for those of you
not familiar with the series since it is
relatively new basically we're going to
be making a game engine from scratch in
this series starting with setting up our
environment which is what this episode
is about so last time I asked you guys
and I talked a bit about the design of
the engine what technologies we were
going to possibly use and I asked you
all the question of which language we
should use so whether that be C++ or
Java now I've gone through all the
comments as of I think basically when
they were about 238 comments I went
through them and the results were enter
these awesome charts I prepared based on
the amount of comments so essentially if
someone would vote for C++ in a comment
or Java for a comment I counted the
amount of comments that essentially
voted for either C++ or Java and these
are these are the results so 121
comments wanted C++ ver whereas only 39
comments wanted Java so that's that and
then one more piece of data is I also
counted the amount of likes that those
comments had so for example there was a
huge one that had about 80 facts and
that was a C++ comment so based on those
Java actually has a better chance but
still 351 comments plus likes for um C++
and only 127 for Java so that means
we're going to be using C++ so let's
begin so the first thing I've done is
I've actually created a brand new user
called Sparky
so that I'm going to try and emulate
basically a completely fresh development
environment as much as possible because
of course I want you guys to be able to
follow along and I'm basically really
starting from scratch here so the first
thing we're gonna want to do is open
your web browser your favorite web
browser and type in Visual Studio
community okay
there'll be a link to the download by
the way in the description below so you
guys don't actually have to follow along
this closely but if we click on the free
dev tools we're going to be using Visual
Studio community that 2013 now I've
never used this before
I yeah I've got no clue so hopefully
this is I've only used a visual she did
professional so I don't know if this has
all the features I haven't really read
about it too much apparently it's just a
more powerful visual studio express so
hopefully it's going to be good so let's
just hit the download button wait for it
to download and that was quick
because it's actually going to just
download the Installer but if we open
this my computer needs to be restarted
okay so I'll see you guys in a minute
all right so once my computer restarted
I actually had to uninstall Visual
Studio 2013 professional to get this to
work but anyway open the Installer and I
mean you don't have to join the program
but you have to agree to the license
terms and whatever hit next now out of
this stuff we really don't need pretty
much any of it I will install a
Microsoft foundation class for C++ we
shouldn't really need them anyway
because we are kind of going for a
cross-platform on platform dependants
kind of engine thing but I will install
them just in case everything else we
don't need so I mean it takes a gig by
itself anyway so we want to minimize
that but that's pretty much all we'll
need so he did install accept the thing
allow it to installed on your on your
computer and then just wait this will
take a while so I'll see you guys when
this is done all right so when the
installation finally finishes it'll be a
big launch button click it and I can get
it analyzed folder and Visual Studio
community 2013 should launch ok so
you'll probably have to sign in first so
go ahead and do that alright and once
you've signed in they should get
everything ready and essentially you
just have to sign in with your Microsoft
account by the way if you've got any
Microsoft account that should work so
just wait for this to UM prepare itself
for first use alright so once Visual
Studio 2013 is open this is what you
should see this is like the blank kind
of startup page okay so the IDE or the
integrated development environment we'll
be using is Visual Studio as you can
probably tell since you just installed
it this is Windows only so unfortunately
you're going to have to develop this on
Windows if you've got a Mac I reckon
and probably just installing Windows via
you know bootcamp essentially dual
booting it if you want to fall follow
along with this
my preferred development environment for
really any kind of software development
here's Windows so I try and if I'm
developing something for an iPhone for
example usually I'll still develop it on
Windows and then when the time is right
you know and I'll have to compile it
using Xcode then I will switch to Mac
but essentially 99% is on Windows so
it's just it is literally just my
preferred development environment of
course a lot of people like Mac I prefer
Windows for software development so
you'll see this stuff I like to
rearrange this stuff and in Kyle you
guys will kind of see that but all we're
gonna do what we're gonna do right now
is just make sure everything is working
and our compile is set up and everything
so I'm just gonna click on new project
you'll see a bunch of templates just go
down to visual C++ and then under that
you should just see probably under
general empty project okay this is what
we want now it'll store it in your
documents under a under villagiulio 2013
on projects so you can just basically
navigate to that place on disk you can
store it somewhere else if you wish to
I'll just start here so the name you
give it is well we'll call it hello
world for now but the idea is this
breaks down into two things name and
solution name so the name is the name of
the actual project okay
whereas solution name it's obviously the
name of the solution so solutions are
like groups of projects so essentially
if you're used to eclipse in Java
think of the solution as like a
workspace right it's just a folder full
of projects right and then the project
is actually the thing that you compile
on the thing that creates your your game
and obviously if you have multiple
projects linked up together this works
the same way ok so hello so the solution
is like the workspace and the project is
the project so let's just hit OK and
wait for it to open all right cool so
it's open now this is on the right hand
side by default I like it on the left
and we won't need properties at all by
the way so we can get rid of that so if
you just click and drag that and you can
kind of snap it over here that's how I
like it
and then on the source files let's just
go ahead and add a new item we'll call
it Maine dot CPP okay great it's open so
over here I'm going to just type in a
basic hello world application so we
don't even need any command-line
arguments or anything and essentially
all we'll do is we'll print out hello
world and then since we're on Windows we
can just use pause as well here and then
we'll just open this up and wait for it
to compile all right cool there we go so
everything's set up properly just
quickly to mention what's going on I hit
the local windows debugger or f5 to
actually open the program if you are
following if you're trying to follow
along with this on Xcode or Mac or any
other Linux on code blocks or whatever
you probably won't be able to use system
pause because this is a Windows API
thing so instead what you can do is
actually use STD C and get okay so that
will request the next character as you
can see it will just kind of pause your
application if you hit a character it'll
kind of request things until you hit
Enter okay so that's the kind of
cross-platform alternative since we're
on Windows though I'll just use system
pause since that works sometimes see and
doc yet doesn't really work but um
there we go that's how hello world
application so I'm using a special theme
here it's called I actually made it
actually so I can't really tell what it
is but I will I'll put up a link in the
description so you guys can download it
and then to set it up
all you'll have to do is go ahead and go
to in fact I could probably just set
this up for you guys properly so if you
go ahead and go to where are we so tools
import and export settings I'm going to
export my settings for you so let's see
it's awesome we don't need that we don't
need that we don't need that general
settings I'll keep and options and all
the options like the text editor stuff
should have stuff like colors and
everything I'll keep all this stuff in
here so if you just hit if
next on that and we'll export it I'll
save it as Cherno vs China visual studio
okay and then what you'll have to do is
once you download it it will be in
visual to your 2013 sorry once you
download the file that will be in the
description the settings file go to your
documents videos to your 2013 settings
and then just paste it in there it'll be
called China vs alright and if we were
in like just normal settings so if we
reset everything it'll look like this
which is the old kind of style I don't
know if it remembers that yeah it'll
remember the positions of everything so
if we go ahead now and go to tools
import sources is what your guys people
will look like you can just import the
selected environment settings don't
worry about you again if you've got your
settings you can save them out and
they'll remember so that you can load
them in if you don't like my ones or
whatever hit next and then under my
settings you should see the China vs hit
next
I hit finish and it should load
everything alright
any can hear close okay there we go
so those are my settings I'll have them
in the description so you can download
them and we're pretty much ready to
start this engine now what I want to
mention quickly before I finish is
because I do want to keep this kind of
interact as well so the question right
now is going to be do you guys want some
kind of C++ review or primer kind of
video in which maybe it'll be like an
hour long or something where I just
literally go through the basics of C++
and show you guys how to do I guess
general and common things because I'm
aware that a lot of you guys who voted
for Java only did so because you didn't
notice a fast Blas and you were
concerned about your ability to follow
along with this so if you guys want me
to make a video before we start this
engine which is just a general review of
C++ and like a primer essentially let me
know I'd be happy to do that I'll go
through the basics of using Visual
Studio as well as the actual language
and I'm sure that will help you guys out
a lot so let me know if you want that
leave a comment below and other than
that I'll see you guys next time
come back